[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
VIJAY GADEPALLY: I hope you all
are enjoying the class so far.
It's always
interesting-- we have
people with a variety
of backgrounds
here, so it's just great to kind
of hear the questions as we're
going along.
So I'm going to
give a quick example
to begin the class right
now that kind of drive
in some of the concepts
that we talked about
on the first class.
But this is kind
of real rather than
sort of cartoon neural networks.
But it's sort of a real
research result that we have.
Before I begin,
I'd like to thank
Emily Do who was one
of my graduate students
who actually did all the work.
I just put some of the
slides together-- not even
all of them, just a few.
So really, the credit for
this work goes to Emily.
Anything I misrepresent
is my fault, not hers.
She graduated, so I'll
take the blame for anything
that's not interesting.
So with that, we'll begin.
All right, so the overall
goal of this project
was really to detect and
classify network attacks
from real internet traffic.
And in order to do this,
as many of you can imagine,
we had to find a data
set that was of interest.
So this is probably
a problem many of you
are currently
thinking about, which
is what data set should
I get my hands on?
Right, so we have a
variety of data sets.
Some are sensitive
in nature, right?
So think of internal
network traffic
that we're trying to collect.
No one's going to let us hand
this over to graduate students
to kind of work on, and then
more importantly, publish.
So the first thing
that we wanted to do
was look for a data set that
was kind of open and out there.
And we're fortunate that there
is a group in Japan called
the MAWI working group, which
stands for the measurement--
and I'll use my cool tool--
the measurement and
analysis of wide area
internet traffic
working group, that
actually has 10 gig
link that they've
tapped using a network tap.
And they actually make
this data available.
It's actually continuously
updated even to today.
So that's really cool,
and this is within that.
It's called the Day-in-the-Life
of the Internet.
And so this has been going
on for multiple years.
The data set is reasonably
large when you convert it
into what we call an
analyst friendly form, which
is something that you or I could
read and make some sense out
of.
take the results
of the manipulation
back into the real world.
That's a really productive
way to think about things
and, really, the basis for a
lot of what we do here at MIT.
This concept is essentially
the basis of modern
or ancient Western
thought on mathematics.
If you remember your
history courses,
this concept of ideal
shapes and ideal circles
is the foundation of
platonic mathematics
some 2,500 years ago.
And at the time, though,
that they were developing
that concept, this
idea that there
are ideal shapes out there
and that thinking about them
and manipulating them
was a more effective way
to reason about the real world,
there was a lot of skepticism.
You could imagine
2,500 years ago
someone is walking
around and saying,
I believe there are
these things called
ideal circles and ideal
squares and ideal shapes.
But they don't actually
exist in nature.
That would probably
not be well-received.
In fact, it was
not well-received.
Many of those philosophers
who were thinking about this
were very negatively received.
And, in fact, if
you want to learn
about how negative the
response was to this,
I encourage you to go and read
the Allegory of the Cave, which
is essentially the story of
these philosophers talking
about how they're
trying to bring
the light of this knowledge
to the broader world
and how they essentially
get killed because of it,
because people don't
want to see it.
So that struggle they
experienced 2,500 years ago,
it exists today.
You as people at MIT will try
and bring mathematical concepts
into environments
where people are like,
I don't see why that's relevant.
And you will experience
negative inputs.
But you should rest assured
that this is a good bet.
It's worked well for
thousands of years.
You know, it's what
I base my career on.
People ask me, well,
what's the basis of it?
Well, I'm just
betting on math here.
It's been a good tool.
So this is why we're beginning
to think this way when
we talk about big data
and machine learning.
So really looking at
the fundamentals, what
are the ideals that we need
in order to effectively reason
about the problems
that we're facing today
in the virtual world,
right, and the fact
that this mathematical concept
described the natural world so
well and also described
in the virtual world
is sometimes called the
unreasonable effectiveness
of mathematics.
You can look that up.
But people talk about math.
Why does it do such a good job
of describing so many things?
And people say, well,
they don't really know.
But it seems to be a good bit of
luck that it happens that way.
So circles, that gets
us a certain way.
But in most of the
fields that we work with,
and I would say that, in
almost any introductory course
that you take in college,
whatever the discipline is,
whether it be chemistry
or mechanical engineering
or electrical engineering
or physics or biology,
the basic fundamental
theoretical ideas
that they will
introduce to you will be
the concept of a linear model.
So there we have a
linear model, right?
And why do we like
linear models?
And again, it can be physics.
It can be as simple as F
= MA Or, in chemistry, it
can be some kind of
chemical rate equation.
Or in mechanical
engineering it can
be basic concepts of friction.
The reason we like these
basic linear models
is because we can
project, right?
I know that if that
solid line represents
what I believe
to-- you know, if I
have evidence to support
that that is correct,
then I feel pretty good about
projecting maybe where I don't
have data or into a new domain.
So linear models allow
us to do this reasoning.
And that's why in the
first few weeks of almost
any introductory course they
begin with these linear models,
because they have proven
to be so effective.
Now, there are many
non-linear phenomena that
are tremendously important, OK?
And as a person who deals
with large-scale computation,
those are a staple
of what people do.
But in order to do non-linear
calculations or reason
about things
non-linearly, it usually
requires a much more complicated
analysis and much more
computation, much more data.
And so our ability
to extrapolate
is very limited, OK?
It's very limited.
So here I am talking
about the benefits
of thinking mathematically,
talking about linearity.
What does this have to do with
big data and machine learning?
So we would like to be able to
do the same things that we've
been able to do in other
fields in this new emerging
field of big data.
And this often
deals with data that
doesn't look like the
traditional measurements we
see in science.
This can be data that has to do
with words or images, pictures
of people, other types
of things that don't feel
like the kinds of data
that we traditionally
deal with in science
and engineering.
But we know we want
to use linear models.
So how are we going to do that?
How can we take this
concept of linearity,
which has been so powerful
across so many disciplines,
and bring them to
this field that
just feels completely
different than the kinds data
that we have?
So to begin with, I need to
refresh for you what it really
means to be linear.
Before, I showed you a line
and, hence, the line, linear.
But mathematically, linearity
means something much deeper.
And so here's an equation
that you may have first seen
in elementary school.
We basically have
to two times three
plus four is equal to two times
three plus two times four.
That is called the
distributive property.
It basically says multiplication
distributes over addition.
And this is the
fundamental reason
why I would say mathematics
works in our world, right?
If this wasn't true very
early on in the earliest
days of inventing
mathematics, it would not
have been very useful, right?
To say that I have two of three
plus four of something, OK,
and then I can
change it and do it
in this other way, that's really
what makes mathematics useful.
And from a deeper perspective,
the distributive property
is basically what
makes math linear.
This is the property that,
if this property holds,
then we can reason
about a system linearly.
Now, you're very familiar
with this type of mathematics,
but there's other
types of mathematics.
So if you'll allow
me, hopefully you
will let me just replace
those multiplication symbols
and addition symbols with this
funny circle times and circle
plus.
And we'll get to why
I'm going to do that.
Because it turns
out that, while you
have done most of your careers
with traditional arithmetic
multiplication and
addition, the kind
you would do on your
calculator or have
done in elementary
school, it turns out
there's other
pairs of operations
that also obey this property,
this distributive property,
and, therefore, allow
us to potentially build
linear models of very
different types of data
using this property.
So, as I mentioned,
the classic two
are circle plus is just equal
to regular arithmetic addition,
as we show on the first
line, and circle times is
equal to regular
arithmetic multiplication.
So those are the standard ones.
And, by far, this pair,
this is the most common pair
that we use across
the world today.
But there are others.
So, for instance, I can
replace the plus operation
it's next to a table or stuff like that. Some
early research going on in that area. And
certainly, the next wave of this is what we
call abstraction. And there is very little
work on this, but if we have to think out
in the future.
But this is really the system of the ability
of an AI system to actually abstract information
that it's learning. So instead of learning
that a chair or a table is something with
a leg at the bottom, it learns that a table
is something you put things on and is able
to abstract that information or that knowledge
to any other domain or any other field. Do
we have any questions before I continue from
here? OK, great.
So that's a little bit on the evolution of
AI. The reason we like to go through this
is because there is great work going on in
each of these waves. And nothing that people
are doing in any of these waves is any lesser
or more. It's typically dependent on what
you have at your disposal.
What I like to tell people sometimes is the
way to think about all of this is you have
a couple of dials at your disposal-- turning
dials. The first dial is, how much compute?
Right? How much ability do you have to crunch
data? The second piece is, how much data do
you actually have available? This can be labeled
data in many cases.
And the third dial is, how much knowledge
are you able to embed into an algorithm? In
certain cases where maybe you have very little
computing, very little labeled data availability,
but a lot of expert knowledge or a lot of
ability to encode information into an algorithm,
you might be able to use an expert system,
right? And that's a very good use case for
that.
An example may be on another dimension where
you want to encode very little human knowledge,
but you have a lot of computing and data available,
would be rare neural networks fall in, where
they're essentially learning what the human
knowledge-- what that encoded information
should be.
A lot of statistical techniques also fall
into that camp where maybe you encode a little
bit of information as to what the background
distribution of the process is. But it learns
the details of exactly how that distribution
is modeled, based on the data that it sees.
So you have a lot of different settings that
you can use. And there are a number of different
techniques within the broader AI context that
you can use to achieve your mission. And I'm
sure many of you are going to be doing different
types of algorithms. And a lot of that decision
will be dependent on, well, how much data
was I given? Right? How good is this data
that I'm using? Is there an ability to learn
anything from this?
And if not, you might have to encode some
knowledge of your own into it saying, well,
I know that this process looks like that,
so let me tell the algorithm to not waste
too much time crunching the data to learn
the underlying distribution, which I can tell
and the linear equation
will still hold.
And, in fact, that's probably
the key concept in big data,
is the necessity to
reason about data
as whole collections and
transforming whole collections.
Going and looking at things
one element at a time
is essentially the thing that is
extremely difficult to do when
you have large amounts of data.
A, B, and C can be
database tables, right?
Those don't differ too
much from spreadsheets.
And as I talked to you
in the previous slide,
that union/intersection
pair naturally lines up
and we can reason
about whole tables
in a database using
linear properties.
They can be matrices.
I think, for those of you
who have had a linear algebra
and matrix mathematics,
that would have been
the first example, right, when
I substituted the A, B, and C
and had these linear equations.
Often, in many of
the sciences, we
think about matrix
operations and linearity
as being coupled together.
And through the duality
between matrices and graphs
and networks, we can
represent graphs and networks
through matrices.
Any time you work
with a neural network,
you're representing that
network as a matrix.
And, of course, all these
equations apply there as well
and you can reason about
those systems linearly.
So that provides a
little motivation there.
As we like to say,
enough about me,
let me tell you about my book.
So this will be the text that
will we use in the class.
We are not going to go
through the full text,
but we have printed out copies
of the first seven chapters
that we will go through.
And we will hand those out
later when you do the class.
So let me now switch
gears a little bit
and talk about how this
relates to, I think,
one of the most
wonderful breakthroughs
that we have seen, or
I've seen in my career,
and many of my colleagues
here at MIT have seen,
which is what's been going
on in machine learning,
right, which is-- it's not hype.
There's a real real there there
and it's tremendously exciting.
So let me give you a little
history, basic history
of this field.
So in a certain sense,
before 2010, machine learning
looked like this.
And then, after 2015, it
kind of looks like this.
So when people talk about
the hype in machine learning,
or AI, really deep
neural networks
are the elephant inside
the machine learning snake.
It has stormed onto the
scene in the last five years
and basically allowed us to do
things that we had almost taken
for granted were impossible.
Just the fact that you're
able to talk to computers
and they can understand you,
that we can have computers that
can see at least in a way that
approximates the way humans do,
these are really almost
technological miracles
that, for those of us
who have been working
on this field for fifty years,
we had almost literally given
up on.
And then all of a sudden
it became possible.
So let me give you a little
sense of appreciation
for this field and its roots.
So machine learning,
like any field,
is defined as a set of
techniques and problems.
When you ask what defines
a field, you ask, well,
what are the problems that they
work on that other fields don't
really work on?
And what are the techniques
they employ that really are not
really being employed by them?
So the core techniques,
as I mentioned earlier,
are these neural networks.
These are meant to crudely
approximate maybe the way
humans think about problems.
We have these circles
which are neurons.
They have connections
to other neurons.
You know, those connections
have different weights
associated with them.
As information
comes in, they get
multiplied by those weights.
They get summed together.
And if they pass certain
thresholds or criteria,
then they send a signal
on to another neuron.
And this is, to
a certain degree,
how we believe the
human brain works and is
a natural starting
point for, how could
we make computers
do similar things?
The big problems that
people have worked on
are these classic problems
in machine learning,
are language, how do we
make computers understand
human language, vision,
how do we make computers
see pictures or explain
pictures back to us the way
we would like, and strategy and
games and other types of things
like that.
So how do we get them
to solve problems?
This is not new.
These core concepts trace
back to the earliest days
of the field.
In fact, these four
figures here, each one
is taken from a paper
that was presented
at the very first
machine learning
conference in the mid-1950s.
So there was a machine learning
It was in Los Angeles.
It had four papers presented.
These were the four papers.
And I will say
that three of them
were done by folks at MIT
Lincoln Laboratory, which
is where I work.
And so that was basically
the neural networks
of language and vision.
And we didn't play
games, so that was it.
And you might say,
well, why is it?
Why was there so
much work going on
in Lincoln Laboratory
in the mid-1950s
that they would want to
pioneer in these directions?
At that time, people were
first building computers
and computers were
very special purpose.
So different organizations
around the world
were building computers
to do different things.
Some were doing them to simulate
complex fluid dynamics systems,
think about designing
ships or other types
of things like
that or airplanes.
Others were doing them to,
say, like what Alan Turing was
doing, break codes.
And our task was
to help people who
were watching radar scopes
make decisions, right?
How could computers enable
humans to watch more sensors
and see where they're going?
How could we do that?
So at Lincoln Laboratory, we
were building special purpose
computers to do this.
And we built the
first large computer
with reliable, fast memory.
This system had 4,096 bytes
of memory, which, at the time,
people thought was too much.
What could you possibly
do with 4,096 numbers?
The human brain, of course!
Right, that's enough, right?
Most of us can remember five,
six, seven digits, right?
So a computer that can
remember 4,096 numbers
should be able to do things
like language and vision
and strategy.
So why not?
So they went out
and they started
working on these problems, OK?
But Lincoln Laboratory, being
an applied research laboratory,
we are required to get answers
to our sponsors in a few years'
time frame.
If problems are going to
take longer than that,
then they really are the
purview of the basic research
community, universities.
And it became
apparent pretty early
on that this problem was
going to be more difficult.
It was not going to
be solved right away.
So we did what we often
do, is we partnered.
We found some bright young
people at MIT, people
just like yourselves.
In this case, we found a young
professor named Marvin Minsky.
And we said, why don't you go
and get some of your friends
together and create
a meeting where
you can lay out what the
fundamental challenges are
of this field?
And then we will figure out how
to get that funded so that you
can go and do that research.
And that was the famous
Dartmouth AI conference
which kicked off the field.
And the person leading this
group, Oliver Selfridge
at Lincoln Laboratory, basically
arranged for that conference
to happen and then subsequently
arranged for what would
became the MIT AI Lab that was
founded by Professor Minsky.
And likewise,
Professor Selfridge
also realized that we would
need more computing power.
So he left Lincoln
Laboratory and formed
what was called Project MAC,
which became the Laboratory
for Computer Science.
And then those two entities
later merged 30 years later
to become CSAIL.
So that was the initial thing.
Now, it was pretty clear that,
when this problem was handed
off to the basic
research community,
there was a feeling that
these problems would
be solved in about a decade.
So we were really
thinking by the mid-1960s
is when these problems
would be really solved.
So it's like giving someone
an assignment, right?
You all are given
assignments by professors
and they give you
a week to do it.
But it took a little longer.
In this case, it took five weeks
or, in this case, five decades
to solve this problem.
But we have.
We have now really,
using those techniques,
made tremendous progress
on those problems.
But we don't know why it works.
So we made this
tremendous progress
but we don't really
understand why this works.
So let me show you a little
bit what we have learned,
and this course will explore
the deeper mathematics
to help us gain insight.
We still don't
know why it works.
At least we can
lay the foundations
and maybe you can figure it out.
So here I am, fifty
years later, a person
from Lincoln Laboratory
saying, "All right.
Question one has been answered.
Here's question two."
Ha.
Why does this work and
hopefully you can begin,
be the generation
figured it out.
Hopefully it'll take
less than fifty years.
Historically this type
once we know how it works,
it usually takes about twenty
years to figure out why.
So I mean impasses
but maybe maybe you
know some people are smarter and
they'll figure it out faster.
So this is what a neural
network looks like.
On the left you have your input,
in this case, a vector, y zero.
It's just these dots
that are called features.
What is a feature?
Anything can be a feature.
That is the power
of neural networks,
is they don't require you
to a priori state what
the inputs can be.
They can be anything.
People have said,
well, you know,
neural networks,
machine learning,
it's just curve fitting.
Yeah, but it's curve fitting
without domain knowledge.
Because domain knowledge
is so costly and expensive
to create that having a
general system that can do this
is really what's so powerful.
So the inputs: we
have a input feature.
It could be a vector,
which we call y sub zero.
And that can just be an image,
right, the canonical thing
being an image of a cat, right?
And that can just be
the pixels, values just
rolled out into a vector,
and they will be the inputs.
And then we have a
series of layers.
These are called hidden layers.
The circles are often
referred to as neurons, OK?
And each line
connecting each dot
has a value associated
with it, a weight.
And the strength
of the connection
between any two neurons
is given by that weight.
And then, ultimately,
the output, in this case,
the output classification,
the series of blue dots there,
are the different
possible categories.
So if I put in a cat picture,
one of those dots would be cat,
maybe one would be dog, maybe
one would be apple or orange,
whatever I desired.
And the whole idea is that,
if I put in a picture of a cat
and I set all these
values correctly,
then the dot
corresponding to cat
will end up with the
highest score, right?
And then I mentioned earlier
that each one of these neurons
collects inputs.
And if it's above a
certain threshold,
it then chooses to pass on
information to the next.
And that's where these b
values, which are vectors,
are just the
thresholds associated
with each one of those.
It's a vector, one value
associated with each one
of those that does those.
This entire system can
be represented relatively
simply with one
equation, which is
that yi plus one, which is
the next vector in the layer,
OK, can be computed by
the previous vector, yi
matrix multiplied
by the weight, W.
So whenever you
see transformations
from one set of neurons to the
next layer, you should think,
oh, I have a matrix that
represents all those weights
and I'm going to multiply it by
the vector to get the next one.
Then we apply these
thresholds, all right?
So we add these,
the bi's, and then
we have a function that
we pass it through.
Typically, this h function
has been given the name
rectified linear unit.
It's much simpler than that.
It's just, if the value is
greater than what comes out
of this matrix multiplied,
if the value is greater
than zero, don't touch it.
Just let it pass through.
If it's less than zero,
make it zero, right?
You know, it's a
pretty complicated name
for a very simple function.
That's actually critical.
If you didn't have
that h function,
this nonlinear
function there, then we
could roll up all
of these together
and we would just have one
big matrix equation, right?
So that's really considered a
pretty important part of it.
So that's pretty
much what's going on.
When you want to know what the
big deal is of neural networks,
that's all that's going on.
It's just that equation.
The challenge is we don't know
what the W's and the b's are.
And we don't know how many
layers there should be.
And we don't know how
many neurons there
should be in each layer.
And although the features
can be arbitrary,
picking the right
ones do matter.
And picking the right
categories do matter.
So when people talk about,
I do machine learning
or I'm off working
on-- they're basically
playing with all
of these parameters
to try and find
the ones that will
work best for their problem.
And there's a lot
of trial and error.
And you'll hear
about there's now
systems that try and use
machine learning to do
that process automatically.
You know, how do you
make machines that learn
how to do machine learning?
The basic approach is a
trial and error approach.
I take a whole bunch
of pictures of cats
that I now have cats in them,
OK, and other things, right?
And I randomly set all those
weights and thresholds.
And I put in the vector
and I see what the system--
I guess what I think the
number of layers and neurons
and all that should be and
I run it through the system
and I get an estimate
or a calculation
for what I think these
final values should be
and I compare it with the truth.
That is, I just
basically subtract it.
And then I use those corrections
to very carefully adjust
the weights.
Basically, with the
last weights first, I
do what's called back propagate
these little changes to try
and make a better guess on
what these weights should be.
So if you hear the
term back propagation,
that's that process of
taking those differences
and using them to adjust
these weights by about
0.01% at a time.
And then we just do
this over and over
again until eventually
we get a set of weights
that we think does the problem
well enough for our purpose.
So that's called back
propagation, all right?
Once we have the set
of weights and we
have a new picture that
we want to know what
it is, we drop it in
there and it tells us
it's a cat or a dog or whatever.
That forward step
is called inference.
These are two words
you'll hear frequently
in machine learning, back
propagation and inference.
And that's all there is to it.
There's really
nothing else to that.
If you can understand
this equation,
you'll be way ahead of most
people in machine learning,
you know?
You know, there's
lots of people who
understand about all the
software and the packages
and the data.
All of them are just doing that.
And I'd say this is one
of the most powerful ways
to be ahead in your field,
is to actually understand
the mathematical principles.
Because then the software
and what it's doing
is much clearer.
And other people
who don't understand
these mathematical principles,
they're really guessing.
They're like, oh,
well, I do this
and I throw this module in.
They don't really know
that all it's doing
is making adjustments to
these various equations,
how many different layers
there are and stuff like that.
Now, why is this important?
You're like, well,
what does it matter?
As I said before,
we have this system.
It works but we don't know why.
Well, why is it
important to know why?
Well, there's two reasons.
One is that, if we want
to be able to apply
this incredible innovation to
other domains-- so many of you
probably want to do that.
Many of you want to say,
how can I apply machine
learning to something else
other than language or vision
or some of these other
standard problems?
I kind of need some
theory to know.
Like, OK, if I have a problem
that's like this one over here
and I changed it in
this way, there's
a good chance it'll work.
There's some basis for why I'm
going to try something, right?
Right now there's a
lot of trial and error.
It's like, well, it's an idea.
But if you can have
some math that says,
you know, I think that
will probably work,
that really is a great way
to guide your reasoning
and guide your efforts.
Another reason is
that-- so here's
a picture of a very
cute poodle, right?
And the machine learning
system correctly
identifies it as poodle.
One thing we realized
is that the way you
and I see that picture is
actually very, very different
than the way the neural network
sees that picture, all right?
And, in fact, I can make
changes to that picture that
are imperceptible to you
or me but will completely
change how the
neural network-- that
is, given our neural network,
I can basically make it
think anything, right?
And so, for instance,
this is a famous paper.
And they got the system
to think that that
was an ostrich, right?
And you can basically show
this for anything, right?
So what's called robust AI,
or robust machine learning,
machine learning that
can't be tricked,
is going to become more
and more important.
And again, having a deeper
understanding of the theory
is very, very critical of that.
So how are we going to do this?
What's the main concept
that we are going
to go through in this class?
This has mostly
been motivational.
But how are we going to
understand the data at a deeper
level?
You know, what's the big idea?
And the big idea is
captured now in this,
I apologize for this
eye chart slide,
which is what we call
declarative mathematically
rigorous data.
So we have this
mathematical concept
called an associative array.
And it's corresponding algebra
that basically encompasses
the data you would put
in databases, the data
that you would put in
graphs, the data that
would put in matrices and it
makes it all a linear system.
And the key operations are
outlined there at the bottom.
If you recall, we have
our basic little addition
and multiplication.
And then what's going
to be very important,
probably the real
workhorse for this-- and i
didn't show it before--
is called essentially
array multiplication or
matrix multiplication.
And that's the far
one on the right
there, which we often abbreviate
just with no symbol, just A B.
But if we really want
to explicitly call out
that its matrix multiplication
as a combination
of both multiplication
and addition,
we put in what we call the
punch-drunk emoji, which
is a plus dot times.
You're probably all young
enough that you don't even
remember emojis when
they had to type them out
with just little characters and
we didn't have icons, right?
So that meant you went to the
bar and lost to the fight,
right?
But, anyway, that's really going
to be the workhorse of what
we're doing here.0:31:08.020
to cover in a few minutes.
That is, it takes people
a long time to figure out,
oh simple tables are good.
We can organize
our data that way.
And just having a good set of
folder names and file names
really solves most of
the problem, right?
That's the beauty
of the solution.
It sounds so
phenomenally simple.
How could it possibly work?
That's actually--
you know, if there's
one thing we figure
out here at MIT,
it's that simple can be
very good and very powerful.
So as was mentioned before,
sort of these neural networks,
as depicted here, drive
this space of applications.
Most of the innovations we've
seen in the past few years
have been using these
neural networks.
This one slide sort of covers
all of neural networks.
In one slide, you
have the picture,
you have the input features,
which are shown in gray dots,
you have the output
classifications
that are shown in
blue dots, and then
you have their neural
network and all
their various weight matrices
or weight tables in between.
If you had one goal, in
terms of understanding AI,
making a commitment to
understanding this one slide,
then you pretty much
understand a good fraction
of the entire field.
And while you are
here at MIT, please
feel free to talk to any
of us about this slide
or these concepts and
we will work with you
to help you understand it.
Because anyone who's
ever coming to you
and offering an AI solution
that uses neural networks, which
is a significant fraction of
them, they're just doing this.
This is all they're doing.
It's all on this one slide.
Many of them, by the
way, do not know the math
that one equation here
that's in this this.
They have software,
they play with knobs,
but they don't even understand
the underlying mathematics.
And just understanding this
math, taking the time to do it,
you will know more than
anyone who is actually trying
to sell you AI solutions.
Now, as Sid said, he
talked about batch size--
I just added batches
to this figure
to emphasize the fact
that all of these letters
are mostly uppercase.
And if you want to know one
thing about matrix math,
it is the easiest way to
go from a vector equation
to a matrix equation is to
take all the lowercase letters
and make them uppercase.
And most of the time,
that actually just works.
In fact, typically
what we do if you're
a linear algebraic
person, is we do that,
and see if it breaks anything.
And if it doesn't
break anything,
well, we assume it's right.
And all of these matrices,
right, are tabular.
A matrix is just a big table.
It's a great big spreadsheet.
So basically, all of
neural networks in AI
is just about taking
spreadsheets and transforming
them.
And so, this is just
motivation for why
these tables are so important.
Here is the standard pipeline.
Vijay talked about it briefly.
And again, what we discovered
is that, in most data
analysis, which includes
AI, this pipeline
represents, pretty much, what
most applications are doing.
It's not that any
application does all of that,
but most of the steps
in an application
fall into this pipeline.
Basically, you have raw
data, you parse it, usually
into some tabular format, you
may ingest it into a database.
You then query that database
for a subset to do analysis,
or you might scan
the whole database
if you're doing all
the files, if you
want to do some application
that involves all the data.
And then, you analyze it,
and then you visualize it.
And so, this is sort of
the big steps in a pipeline
that we see.
And again, most
applications that we'll will
use three of these steps.
They're not using
all of them, but it's
a great framework for looking
at any data analysis pipeline.
It's easy to use, it's
easy to understand,
and it's easy to maintain.
And you know, we like
all of those features.
And I'll get into
those in more detail.
And then finally, I've already
talked with significantly
about data sharing.
There's just some
examples of data
we've put up for sharing,
the moments in time
challenge, the graph challenge.
And again, creating,
sharing quality data,
really, it's not just a
service to the community.
It's principally a
service to yourself.
And in fact, we've worked
with a number of applications
and sponsors where
we help them do this,
and they find the data that
they made shareable is instantly
the most valuable data
in their organization
because it's shareable within
their organization too.
The same things that make
it shareable to the broader
community make it shareable
within your organization
to other partners.
So that's really important.
And again, as I said
before, co-designing
the sharing and the
purpose of the data,
is quite you need to do that.
In order to do
effective sharing,
you can't just share
data arbitrarily.
That can be very
difficult to do,
but if you have a particular
application in mind,
sharing the data
is quite simple.
And I'll get into that later.
So I'm just going to,
then, sort of hammer home
some of these points, here.
So nothing really
new, here, just sort
of repeating what I've already
said about these things
but with adding a little
bit more texture, to them.
So why do we like tables?
Well, we've been using
tables to analyze data
for thousands of years.
So on the right is a
12th century manuscript.
It's actually a table of pies.
And if you can read
Latin and Roman numerals,
you already can tell it
is probably, oh, there's
some columns, and
there's some rows.
And those Roman
numerals are numbers.
Even 800 years
later, we can still
see that this is a data table.
And it goes back further.
You can find cuneiform tablets
that are thousands of years old
that are clearly written
in a tabular form.
So humans have been looking
at data in a tabular form
for thousands of years.
Part of that is how our
brain is actually wired.
One, the 2D projection,
since we live in 3D space,
is the only projection
that will show you
all the data without occlusion.
So if you want to
look at all the data,
it kind of has to be
presented in 2D form.
We have a 2D optical system.
In addition, we have special
hard wired parts of our eyes
that detect vertical and
horizontal lines for,
presumably, detecting
the horizon or trees
or who knows what.
And that makes it
very easy for our eyes
to look at tabular data.
And because of
this, tabular data
is compatible with
almost every data
analysis software on earth.
If I make data analysis
software and it
can't read tables
or write out tables,
it's going to have a
very small market share.
And this is just an example of
some of the software out there
that is designed to use tables.
So whether it be spreadsheets or
databases or the neural network
packages that we've
already looked at,
various languages and
libraries, and even
things that you
wouldn't think are
tabular like hierarchical file
formats, like JSON and XML,
can actually be made compatible
with a tablet format.
So I'm just going to
walk through these
in a little more detail.
So of course, our
favorite is spreadsheets.
Here's an example of a
spreadsheet, on the left.
And what's great
about it is that I
have four different types
of data that are very, very
different, and you
can all look at them
and sort of get a
sense of what they are.
And that just shows how flexible
this tabular spreadsheet
form is, is that we can handle
really, really diverse types
of data in a way
that's intuitive to us.
Some of the biggest
pieces of software
that are used that
implement this
are Microsoft Excel, Google
Sheets, Apple Numbers.
It's used by about 100
million people every day.
And so, this is the most popular
tool for using data analysis,
and there's a good
reason for it.
And thinking of things
in a tabular format
so they can be pulled
into this really makes
communication a lot easier.
And so again, just sort of
hammering home this element
of tables.
Within that, there's
specific formats
that we have found
to be very popular.
So CSV and TSV are just
non-proprietary, plain text
ways of organizing data.
We highly encourage people
to use them because then it
can be used by any tool.
CSV just stands for
comma separated values.
It's usually filename.csv in
lower case or filename.CSV
in upper case.
And all it means is
that the columns--
So each row is terminated by a
new line, and within each row
the columns are
separated by a comma.
That's all that means.
We tend to encourage
people to use
TSV, which stands for
tab separated values,
because we can replace
the comma with a tab.
And that allows us to
write higher performance
readers and writers.
Because it is not uncommon to
have a comma within a value,
and so it makes it very
difficult to write parsers
that can do that fast.
But it's OK to say to a
person generating data,
if you put a tab inside a
value that's a foul on you.
You shouldn't do that.
And so that means I can
write a program that
can read this data
really fast, and it can
write this data really fast.
And that's why, in the
big data or AI space,
people often tend to use TSV.
And again, it's easily
readable and writable
by all those
spreadsheet programs
that I have said before.
Databases play a very
important role as well.
There's several different types
of databases that are called
SQL, NoSQL, and NewSQL .
They're good for
different things.
I won't dwell on that
here, but there are
different types of databases.
All of them operate on tables.
In fact, the central
object in a database
is literally called
a database table.
And so, databases play
an important role.
I won't go into detail here,
but I just want to mention this.
Likewise, you've already
had some demonstrations
of different languages
and libraries.
I think everything
you saw was in Python.
There's other languages--
Julia, MATLAB, Octave, R--
many other languages
that play important roles
in data analysis.
We've talked about
Jupyter Notebooks, which
is a universal interface to
these different languages
and libraries to allow you to
do data analysis in addition
to the various machine
learning tools.
We've talked a lot
about TensorFlow,
but there's others--
Theano, Caffe, Nvidia Digits--
all are examples of
different tools for doing AI.
And again, they love
to ingest tabular data,
and they're very good at writing
out tabular data completely
consistent with that here.
And then finally, I want
to mention XML and JSON,
which are very popular in
object-oriented languages,
like C++, Java, and Python.
Those languages rely on data
structures, which are basically
just a set of fields,
and then those fields
can also be data structures,
and this can continue on.
These are called
hierarchical data structures,
the way these languages
are organized.
And so it's very natural
for them to have formats
that they can just say, write
out this whole blob of data,
and it will write it out into
a hierarchical form called
XML or JSON.
However, it's not
very human readable.
And I just told you that
all the data analysis tools
want tables, which means
that these formats aren't
necessarily very good for
doing data analysis on.
Fortunately, we've
discovered some ways
that we can basically convert
these hierarchical formats
into a giant, what we
call, sparse table.
And sparse just means a table
where lots of the values
are empty.
The entries are empty.
And so we can just
use that space
to represent this
hierarchy, and all the tools
we've just talked about can
ingest this data pretty easily.
Because tables are so popular,
every single different approach
or software package--
and we have a bunch of them
listed in the first column,
here--
assign different names
to the standard ways
we refer to the
elements of a table.
And there aren't that many.
So when you think
about a table, there's
certain standard terms
for dealing with what
do we call the table?
In Excel it's called a sheet.
How do we refer to
a particular row?
What do we call a whole row?
How do we refer to
a particular column?
What do we call a whole column?
What do we call an entry?
And what kind of
math can we do on it?
And so, whenever
you're encountering
a new piece of software--
And we deal with it all the
time, but a lot of times
you'll get software, and
maybe it's related to data
analysis seems really,
really confusing.
It's probably working on
tables, and so all you
have to need to learn is what
are they calling these things.
And different software
gives it different names,
just for arbitrary
historical reasons.
And so, if you can figure out
what it's calling these things,
then you'll discover
the software
is a lot easier to understand.
So we definitely encourage you
to just map whatever software
into these concepts,
and all of sudden life
becomes a lot easier.
And because tabular data
is used so commonly,
whether it be in spreadsheets
or analyzing graphs or databases
or matrices, it's a
natural interchange format.
So by reading in tabular data
and writing out tabular data,
you're preserving your
ability to have that data go
into any application.
Again, you have to be
careful about people
who want to write
proprietary formats
because they're
basically, sort of,
preventing you from
basically working
with other tools and
other communities.
And this is another reason
why tabular data is so great.
All right, so moving on
here, I wanted to just talk
about basic files and folders.
So hopefully, you
know, tables are good.
That's sort of lesson one.
And we're going to talk about
how files and folder names,
well chosen is also good.
Right?
Again, this sounds so obvious,
but it's really the thing
that we've discovered,
in working with thousands
of MIT researchers
over the past decade,
that these are the
fundamentals that help you out.
I've already mentioned this
pipeline that we talked about.
It's a way we organize the data.
It's easy to build.
It has built in tools
in every single computer
you have to support this to
just create folders and files.
That means it has
no technical debt.
That is, you never have
to worry about if you
have folders and files
that in 10 years,
oh my god, folders and
files are going to go away.
They've been around
for 50 years,
in pretty much
their present form.
We don't anticipate
them changing.
They're easier to understand.
I already talked about
tabular file formats
and how useful they are.
And we will talk
about a simple naming
scheme for your data files.
AI requires a lot of
data, which means,
often, thousands or
millions of files.
Having good schemes for naming
them really helps you and helps
share the data amongst
people in your team.
They can just look at
the folders and files
and sort of understand
what's going on.
And again, this folder structure
is very easy to maintain,
doesn't require any
special technology,
and anyone can look at it
Getting into some more details
about this table format,
some sort of real, sort of in
the weeds types of things that
are really important.
I've always talked
about you want to avoid
proprietary formats if you can.
Using CSV and TSV are great.
They might be a little bulkier.
You can compress them.
No problem with doing that.
Then you get pretty
much all the benefits
of a proprietary format but in
a way that's generally usable.
Within a TSV or CSV
file, it's good practice
to make sure that each
column label is unique.
So that's actually a big help.
You don't want to
have, essentially,
the same column label or column
name occur over and over again.
And likewise, it's helpful if
the first column are the row
labels, and those are
each unique as well.
And just those two practices
make it a lot easier
to read and organize the data.
Otherwise, you end up having
to do various transformations.
If a lot of the entries
are empty, i.e.,
the table is very sparse,
there's another format we use,
which is sometimes
called triples format.
Basically, every
single entry in a table
can be referred to
by its row label,
it's column label,
and it's value.
That forms a triple.
So you can just write another
file, can be a TSV file,
that has three columns.
The first column
is the row label,
the next column is
the column label,
and the next column
is the value label.
And most software can
read this in pretty nice--
it's a very convenient
way of dealing
with very, very sparse data
without losing any benefits.
So that's a very good thing.
In terms of actual file
naming, as I said before,
you want to avoid having
lots of tiny files.
Most file systems,
most data systems,
do not work with small
files really well.
You do want to compress.
Decompression doesn't
take much time.
It's usually quite beneficial.
And so, it's better to
have fewer larger files.
A sweet spot, for
a long time, has
been file serving the one
megabyte to 100 megabyte range.
This one megabyte
is big enough so
that you can read it in
and get high bandwidth,
get the data into
your program quickly.
And up to 100 megabyte, once
you start going beyond that,
you maybe can start exhausting
the memory of your computer
or your processor.
So this is one megabyte
to 100 megabyte
range has been a sweet
spot for quite a while.
You want to keep directories
to less than 1,000 files.
That's pretty common nowadays.
Creating directories with a
really large number of files,
most systems don't
really like that.
You'll find it's also
hard to work with.
And so, that's something.
You want to keep your
directories less than 1,000.
And so, you do that by using
hierarchical directories.
And so, when it
comes to naming files
to things that tend to
be pretty universal,
is source and time of data.
Right?
Where you collected it
and when you collected
it are pretty fundamental
aspects that you
can rely on being a part
of almost all data sets.
And so, this is a
simple naming scheme
that we use that we
find is very accessible.
We just create a
hierarchical directory here.
It begins with
source, and then we
have the years, the months, the
days, the hours, the minutes,
however far you need
to go to kind of hit
your sort of 1,000
files per folder window.
And then, we repeat
all that name
within the file name itself,
so that if the file ever
gets separated from its
directory structure,
you still have that information.
And that's really important
because it's easy for files
to get separated,
and then, you know,
it's like a kid wandering
around without his parents.
But if it's got a little
label on it that says,
this is my address, then you can
get the get the kid back home.
And likewise,
sometimes you'll do
the time first and then source.
It really depends
on the application.
They're both fine.
But again, this
sounds really simple,
but it solves a lot of problems.
If you give data to
people in this form,
they're going to
know what it means.
Right?
It doesn't require a
lot of explanations.
Like, dates are pretty
obvious, source names
are pretty obvious, and
then they can, basically,
work through it pretty nicely.
Databases and files
can work together.
You'll have some people like,
we do everything with files,
or we do everything
with databases.
They do different things.
They serve different purposes.
So databases are good for
quickly finding a small amount
of data in a big data set.
So if I want to look up a little
bit of data in a big data set,
that's what databases do well.
Likewise, if I want
to read a ton of data,
like all of the data,
and I want it analyzed,
that's what file
systems do well.
So you, a lot of times,
keep them both around.
You have databases for looking
up little elements quickly,
and you have data
and file system
if I want to read a lot of data.
So they work together
very harmoniously, they
serve different purposes.
And again, different databases
are good for different things.
I won't belabor these, you
can read them yourself.
But there are a variety
of database technologies
out there, and they
serve different purposes.
So let me talk about the folder
structure in a little bit
more detail.
This is getting really like--
It is really just this simple.
When we talk about
our standard pipeline,
it's just a bunch of
folders that we name,
like we show on the right.
So we have an overall folder
that we usually call pipeline,
and then we basically label
each step with step 0, step 1,
so people know which is the
beginning and which is the end
and what's happening in there.
So we have step 0 raw,
step one parse, step two
ingest, step three query,
step four analysis,
step five is viz, if
you're doing that.
And then, within each one of
those, we'll have a folder,
we'll have a readme, which
basically tells people
something about, OK,
what's going on there.
Those readmes are really good.
Even if you never share
this data with anybody else,
as you get on in
life, you will often
be asked to revisit
things, and just
having this information so
that two years later, you
can go back and look at it,
is really, really helpful.
Because otherwise,
you'll discover
that you don't remember
what it is you were doing.
So you write a
little readmes that
give you some information
about what's going on.
And then, within
each step, there's
usually readme that
talks to you about what
the instructions in here.
And then, we have
a folder called
code and folder called data.
And basically, the
code describes how
you put data into this folder.
So in the step 0 raw, this
is often the code, maybe,
for downloading the
data from the internet
or how you collected your data.
That's the code that, basically,
puts the data into that folder.
And then, with the
next folder here,
parse, this is the code
that takes this raw data
and parses it and puts
it into this folder.
And then, for
ingest, this will be
the code that takes the
data from the parse form,
sticks it in a
database, and these
might be the log files
of the database entry.
So a lot of times, when you
just data into a database,
you'll have log files that keep
track of what that happened.
And likewise, this
continues on down.
So very simple.
And I would offer to you, if
you someone gave you this,
and you looked at it,
without any documentation,
you'd probably have a pretty
good idea of what's going on.
Oh, this is some
kind of pipeline.
I wonder where it begins.
Probably step 0.
I wonder what that is.
It's probably raw data.
Right?
It's that simple.
And this just makes it so easy.
The more you can
get stuff to people
and they can just
understand it without
any additional explanation,
that's incredibly valuable.
And again, allows your teams to
contribute quickly to projects.
And then, finally, we'll
add a little thing here,
which is a data file list.
This is a list of the
full names of all the data
files because, especially
on our systems,
people are often processing
lots of data, which
contain millions of files.
If you're going to be using
many processors to do that,
it really punishes
the file system
if you ask 1,000 processors to
all traverse a data directory
and build up the file name
so they can figure out which
files they should each process.
Really, that's
actually a great way
to get kicked off a
computer is to have
1,000 processes all
doing ls-l on all
the folders in a new directory
with millions of files.
Right, it will bring the
file system to its knees.
So if you just
have this one file
that you generate
once that lists
all the names of the files,
then every single process
can just read into
that file, pick
which files they want to
read, and then do their work,
and then even know what the
names to write the files are.
And that's, really,
a very efficient way.
It dramatically speeds
up your processing
and keeps the pressure on
the file system at a minimum.
In addition, if you just want
to look at what you have,
you don't have to type ls
to list the directory, which
might ls while.
You can just look at this
file and see what do I have.
Right?
It's very convenient to be able
to know what the data sets are.
And then you can go
in there, and you see,
oh, I see all these, you
know, time stamps and sources.
I know what I have.
Right?
It makes it really easy for
people to get through this.
So finally, I want to talk
about using and sharing.
And so, again, co-design is
using and sharing together.
Most data that you will deal
with starts out unusable
and unshareable,
that is, the data
is not suited for the purpose
that you wanted to use it for,
and you do not have permission
to share with anybody.
And so, if you understand
the data and its purpose,
you can get through
both of those problems.
So, really practical aspects,
here, of data sharing.
We're going to talk about a
few different roles that are
very common in data sharing.
The first is the
keeper of the data.
This is the actual person
who has the ability
to make a copy of the data.
You can talk to lots of
people, but until you
find the keeper of the data, you
haven't really gotten anywhere.
Right?
Because lots-- Oh, yes, we
have data, and we can share it,
or we can give it
to you, et cetera.
And there's someone who
can eventually type a copy
command to the data.
You want to find that person.
That's the person you
really need to work with.
They're the one person who
can really, really help you
because they actually have
hands on access to the data.
So you want to find that.
Then, you want to get a
sample or a copy of the data
to your team to assess.
It is always good to
do good opsec, which
is good operational security,
which means fewer accounts,
fewer people having
access is better.
A lot of times people
say, oh, here's the data.
Give me a list of names that
you want to have access to it.
If you provide them one name,
that's often pretty easy
to get approved.
If you provide 10 names,
now questions will happen.
Why are we giving 10
people access to this data?
You don't really need 10 people
to have access to the data.
You can just have one person get
the data on behalf of the team.
That's relatively
easy to approve.
You start giving a list of
20 names have access data,
now there's all
kinds of questions,
and that may just end
the exercise right there.
And once the question starts
happening, you'll discover,
well, maybe we've lost
that one, and we need
to move on to someone else.
And guess what, that
keeper, do they like you now
that they've raised
all kinds of questions
because of something
they thought was OK?
Well, now we're--
No, you may no
longer have a friend.
Right?
So you've lost a friend,
you've lost a source of data,
so minimizing the
access to the data,
getting just the
people access to it who
need you to make your next
step is a really good practice.
I have been that keeper.
I have been the person
who has to approve things,
and nothing makes me
shut something down
quicker than when someone says,
well, I want 20 people to have
accesses.
I'm like, well, no.
Zero works for me.
That's a number in 20.
(LAUGHS) Right?
That's one of the
numbers, there.
How about zero?
That works for me.
So then, once you get
a copy of the data,
you then convert a sample
of it to a tabular form,
you can identify the useful
columns or features in that,
and then you can
get rid of the rest.
That's a huge service
to your community
is if you have a volume of
data, and you know, like,
all of this stuff is
not going to be useful.
Now you're just giving
people useful data.
That's really, really valuable.
That's sort of a --
And since you're talking
the keeper of the data,
they may have the
most information
about what these different
columns or features mean.
That's not a conversation
that a lot of people
are going to get to have.
And so, if you get to help
your whole team by saying,
oh we know these
columns mean this.
They're not relevant,
let's get rid of them.
That's a huge service
to your community.
It's less data.
It makes it easier to release.
You then, maybe, will, if there
is data columns or features
that are sensitive
in some way, there's
a variety of techniques you
can use to minimize, anonymize,
possibly simulate, or use
surrogate information to make
it so that you can
share that data.
And there's lots of
techniques, but those
are only applicable when
you know your application.
So if I look at this data,
and I see this one column that
might be sensitive but
valuable for my application,
I can often come up
with a minimization
scheme that will work for that.
Because all data
analysis is based
on tables, which is
mathematically just matrices,
one of the most
fundamental properties
of matrices that we
really, really like is
that reordering the
rows or the columns
doesn't change any of the math.
That's kind of, like, the big
deal of matrices and tables.
You can move the row,
reorder the rows,
reorder the columns, and
everything should still just
work, which means if
you relabel the columns
or leave relabel the rows,
things should still just work,
and you'll be able to
do the science you need.
So a lot of times, when you
share data with researchers,
information that normally
you would delete,
that you would think would be
valuable for someone else--
The researcher is
like, I don't care.
Right?
As long as it doesn't
change something fundamental
about the structure of the
data, I can work with that.
And again, that's
something you would never
know unless you have
an end purpose in mind.
So then, you want to obtain
preliminary approval to take--
I have a data set, I've
worked with the keeper,
is it OK for me to share this
with a broader set of people
to make sure that
they like it too?
That's usually easy to do.
It's just a small sample.
And then, you can test
with your AI users.
You repeat this process until
you, basically, have data.
It's like, yeah,
this is what we want,
this is what we want to share,
and then, you can sort of
go through the process
of how do we really get
an agreement in
place to do that.
You also, then,
create the folder
naming structure for scaling
out to more data files.
And then finally,
what's great is
if you can then automate this
process at the data owner's
site.
It's tremendously valuable.
Then you have just gifted
them a data architecture
that makes their data AI ready.
And then, moving
forward, they can now
share with you, within their own
organization, or with others.
Right?
So this is incredibly valuable.
Right, we said data architecture
and wrangling is often
80% of the effort.
You do this, you've now
eliminated potentially
80% of the effort
of anyone else who
ever wants to do data
analysis or AI in this data.
Right?
This is a phenomenally
huge win for anyone
that you partnered with is to
give them a very simple data
architecture they can
maintain going forward.
It's a huge potential
savings to them.
All right, so another
role we want to talk about
is the data owner subject
matter expert, or SME.
So we've talked about
the keeper of the data.
There's often a
subject matter expert
associated with the data
that is an advocate.
The keeper is often like,
hey, I maintain the data.
I do with these subject
matter experts tell me to do.
But there's someone
out there who
wants to help you get the
data because they see it's
going to be valuable to you.
And all these AI data products
are generally best made
by people with AI knowledge.
So we are highly
motivated to engage
with these subject
matter experts,
pull them into the
AI community so they
can see the best practices.
That will allow
them to understand
which data they have, how
it might be useful to AI,
and how to prepare
it, so that's better.
So whenever we get engaged
with subject matter experts
at other communities,
at data owners,
we really want to pull
them into the community,
have them come to
our environments
so they can see what's going on
and help us identify new data
sets and help make
those data sets
appropriate for our consumption.
So one of the big
things you'll run into
is that there are concerns
with sharing data.
That is, there's
a lot of confusion
about the liability of
sharing data with researchers.
And data owners often have
to think about the lowest
common denominator.
If it's a company,
they have to think
about US and EU and
other requirements,
all kinds of
different frameworks
for thinking about that.
The good news is there are
standard practices that
meet these requirements.
And I'm going to list what
these standard practices are.
We have worked
with many folks who
have tried to share
data successfully,
and these are the properties
of successful data sharing
activities.
And the activities that
don't do these things often
are unsuccessful.
We didn't invent any of this.
This is just our observations
from working with many people
who've tried to share data.
One, you want data available
in curated repositories.
Just taking data and
posting it somewhere
without proper curation really
does no good for anyone.
You want to use standard
and anonymization
methods where needed.
Hashing, sampling,
simulation, I've already
talked about those, but those
do work, particularly when they
are coupled with access
requires registration
with a repository
and legitimate need.
So there's a data
agreement associated
with getting the data in
some way, shape, or form.
And those two together
really, really work well.
And you also want
to focus on getting
the data to the people
who are actually
going to add value to it.
So one of the misnomers is,
oh, we'll just take data,
and we'll make it available
to all 10 billion souls
on the planet earth, when,
really, less than 100
could ever actually
add value to us.
So why are we going through
all the trouble and the issues
associated with making data
available to anyone, when
really we only want to get that
data to people with the skills
and legitimate research
needs to make use of it?
And so, by setting up
curated repositories,
people then apply--
I want to get access to data--
they talk about
what their need is.
That sets, sort of, a swim lane.
You can't just do anything
you want with the data.
When you say, I'm going to
use it for this purpose,
you have to stick
to those guidelines.
If you want to change them, you
have to go back and say, look,
I want to do
something different.
If you're a
legitimate researcher
with legitimate research needs,
that's usually pretty easy
to approve.
And then, recipients agree not
to repost the whole data set
or to deanonymize it.
This is what makes
anonymization work.
Not that the anonymization
or the encryption
is so strong it's
unbreakable, it's
that people agree
not to reverse it.
And the good thing about working
with legitimate researchers
is they're highly motivated
not to break their agreements.
If you're at MIT or any
of these universities
and you break your data
sharing agreements,
that is professionally
very detrimental to you
because it is very detrimental
to the organization.
No research or
organization ever wants
to have a reputation that it
does not respect its data usage
agreements.
That will put that research
organization out of business.
So there's a lot of incentive
for legitimate researchers
to honor these
agreements, which may not
be the same for just general
people who are working
in other types of environments.
So they can publish their
analysis and data examples
as necessary, they agree
to cite the repository
and provide the
publications back,
and the repository can
curate enriched products.
So if a researcher discovers
some derivative product--
Look, I can apply
this to all the data.
I'd like to have that
be posted somewhere.
They can often use the
original repository to do that.
And again, we encourage
everyone to encourage people
to follow these guidelines.
They're very beneficial.
So I've talked about
the data keeper.
I've talked about the
subject matter expert.
Now, I'm going to talk about
a final critical role, which
is the ISO, the information
security officer.
In almost every single
organization that has data,
there is an information
security officer
that needs to sign off on making
the data available to anyone
else.
They're the person whose
neck is on the line
and is saying that it's
OK to share this data,
that the benefits outweigh
the potential risks.
And subject matter experts
need to communicate the info
with the information
security officer.
They're often the ones
advocating for this data
to be released, but they don't
know the language information
security officers.
And this causes huge problems.
And, I would say, 90%
of data sharing efforts
die because of miscommunication
between subject matter experts
and information
security officers.
Because the information
security officer fundamentally
needs to believe that
the subject matter
expert understands the risks,
understands basic security
concepts in order for them to
trust them with their signature
to get it released.
And so, typically,
what happens is
that an ISO needs a very basic
information from the subject
matter expert in
order to approve
the release of information.
What's the project?
What's the need?
Where is the data going to be?
Who's going to be
using it for how long?
They are expecting one sentence
answers to each of these.
A subject matter
expert typically
replies with an entire
research proposal.
And so, if I'm an
ISO and I'm trying
to assess whether a subject
matter expert knows anything
about security, and I gave them
really easy softball questions,
and they come back
with something
that clearly took them
way more time and effort
that answers none of
my questions, what's
my opinion going to be of
that subject matter expert
and how much I
should trust them?
It's going to be zero.
And from that moment
onward, I'll be polite but,
you know, how about zero data?
That works for me.
(LAUGHS) Right?
That's a good number, right?
So this is really important.
And so, if there's
one thing we can do--
Because very few
of you are ISOs.
And something that my team
gets involved on a lot
is to intercept this
conversation before it goes
bad, is we can help
you work with ISOs,
work with people who have
to release with data,
and help answer these
questions in a proper way.
And so, I'm going to go
through a few examples, here.
So, a really common question
is, what is the data
you're seeking to share?
So this is a very
common question
to get back from an ISO.
Describe the data to be
shared, focusing on its risk
to the organization if it were
to be accidentally released
to the public or
otherwise misused.
Very common question.
And so, here's an
example answer.
Very short answer.
The data was collected
on these dates
at this location in
accordance with our mission.
The risk has been
assessed and addressed
by an appropriate
combination of excision,
anonymization,
and/or agreements.
The release to appropriate
legitimate researchers
will further our mission and
is endorsed by leadership.
Very, very, very short
answer, but we've
covered a lot of ground
in that short answer.
And I will explain.
Sentence one establishes
the, identity finite scope,
and proper collection of
the data in one sentence.
Sentence two establishes
that risk was assessed
and that mitigations were taken.
Sentence three establishes the
finite scope of the recipients,
an appropriate reason for
release, and mission approval.
We've covered-- we've answered
nine questions in three
sentences at the level
of detail an ISO wants.
An ISO can always ask you more
questions for more detail,
and they're usually looking for
another one sentence answer.
And you build these
up to be three, four,
five sentence things
that cover broadly
what you're wanting to do.
And you see here, you
don't want to do anything
that requires the ISO to have
detailed technical knowledge
of what you're doing.
They're looking for overall
scope, overall limiters
on what you're doing
so that is somehow
contained to a reasonable risk.
Another question, here, that's
very common is where, to whom
is the data going?
So please describe the
intended recipients.
So an example answer is the data
will be shared with researchers
at a specific set
of institutions,
that it will be processed
on those institution's
own systems, meaning their
institutions security policies,
which include password
controlled access,
regular application of
system updates, encryption
of mobile devices,
such as laptops,
all provided access to data will
be limited to personnel working
as part of this effort.
Again, we've covered a
lot of ground very simply.
We didn't really go
into too many details
that are specific to
this particular case.
And then, a final one is
what controls are there
on further release,
either policy or legal?
So an example is an
acceptable use guidelines
that prohibit attempting to
deanonymize the data will
be provided to all personnel
working on the data,
publication guidelines
have been agreed to that
allow for high-level statistical
findings to be published,
but prohibit including any
individual data records.
A set of notional
records has been
provided that can be published
an example of the data format
but is not part of
the actual data set.
The research agreement
requires that all data
be deleted at the
end of the engagement
except those items
retained for publication.
I'm not saying you
have to use this.
But again, this
is another example
of what ISOs are expecting.
You give them language like
this, their confidence swells.
They're like, ah, I'm
dealing with someone
that understands the risks
I'm taking on their behalf.
And we can move forward
in a very productive way.
And if you ever have questions
about how to do this,
feel free to talk to
my team or other people
or other ISOs who've
had to deal with this.
We actually are
working with a lot
of people on this language, a
lot of people the government,
to sort of get these
best practices out there.
We have socialized this with
a fair number of experts
in this field, and
there's general consensus
this is a very good method
for helping you get data out.
So that brings me to
the end of the talk.
So as I said before, data
wrangling is very important,
significant part of the effort.
Analysis really relies
on tabular data,
so that's a really good format.
You can do it in very simple,
non-proprietary formats.
You're going to have
to name your folders
and file something,
you might as well
name something that's
really generally usable.
And then, finally,
co-designing, the sharing,
and what the intent is at
the same time, that's doable.
Generalized release of
data is very, very hard.
Tailored release for
specific applications
is very, very doable if you
have good communication from all
the stakeholders involved.
So these are just
really practical things.
This isn't, sort of, fancy AI.
This is, sort of,
bread and butter,
how do you actually
get data analysis done.
And with that, I'm happy
to take any questions. questions.